quelques notes d'une des dernières
chansons qu'elle est plutôt ils ont
enregistré ensemble le 10 avril 1966 en
entrevue paul mccartney officialisé la
dissolution du groupe
je pense que pour les français une
pandémie christ est une tragédie pour
les femmes sans toutefois être une
véritable surprise après le manager se
sont retrouvés dans un chaos total
et toute la façon où leur affaire avait
été échafaudé il y en a beaucoup qui ont
blâmé yoko ono la séparation des beatles
mais ça serait lui donner un peu
troubles d'importance et c'est surtout
l'affirmation de chaque personnalité
distincte et d'ailleurs on le voyait
plus en plus à la fin avec l'album blanc
par exemple est un album de kat artistes
sur louxor une histoire donc ce que des
constamment capable de se réinventer en
moins de dix ans ces quatre garçons aux
cheveux longs ont opéré une véritable
révolution
[Musique]
l'impression que j'ai quand je pense à
cet important aujourd'hui c'est comme si
avant les beatles la vie sa passion en
noir et blanc puis après les beatles on
voudrait que les couleurs sont venus
s'ajouter dans les années 60 il était
plus populaire que j'y joue moins
qu'avant de trouver un outil culturel
qui réunit chez pour une génération de
jeunes pour la paix par la suite les
baby boomers quelque chose que je dirais
que c'est pas les beats ozon ont été
leurs reflets de cette génération là
mais par la force des choses ils en sont
devenus les leaders aussi la fin du
groupe marque également le début d'un
nouveau chapitre l époque on disait
perdu les vitesses mécanique est artiste
solo les beatles
un phénomène inégalée dans l'histoire de
la musique leurs chansons continuent de
régulièrement trôner dans les palmarès
les redditions de leurs albums se
multiplient et cet automne paraîtra un
nouveau film réalisé par peter jackson
sur le groupe lexsi
[Musique]
s'il a dit alexandre charti radio canada
montréal
[Musique]